i was born in 1938 which is a long time
ago
and it was about seven or eight just
towards the end of the war
when i got into maths
totally accidentally because i met a
fella in a pub
in those days they had children's rooms
because people worked round the clock
and and took all went out with the kids
to the pub to relax chap came up to me i
lived in bristol so he said era how was
your mass then
made me dance i said all right
he said how was your multiplication i
said
all right he said shall i show you how
the russians do what we can do
i said if you like he said come here
come here he says say you want to
multiply 9 times 13. he said you wrote
them sideways like that and what they do
their halves and doubles everything so
what we're going to do is half nine so
give me half a nine i said that's four
and a half he said four and a half oh
hang on he said the russians had purges
things they don't like and one thing
they don't like
is fractions they ate some so we'll
scrub that out call it four alpha nine
is four alpha four is two alpha two is
one that's one side now what you do they
said is you double the other side so two
13s i'll do it you tell me if it's right
26. two of those is 52 and two of those
i'd written four
and now we got four each side now
there's another purge the russians had
one thing they really couldn't stand
worse than fractions they couldn't stand
even numbers
on the left-hand side they couldn't
avoid them well let's have a look well
that's odd but that's even so out goes
the whole row gone that's even out goes
the whole row that's odd so what you've
got left you adds up 13 of 4 is 17 plus
100 and would you believe 9 times 13
equals 117 and that works with any
numbers
every single time i want to see it again
johnny i want to see another example so
can we do another one i'll give it the
other way around it doesn't matter what
numbers you use we'll do 13 times 9.
after 13 six and a half forget the half
half of six three half of three one and
a half forget the half two nines
eighteen two eighteens thirty six two
36's 72 and we got four each side
but there's an even one here on the
left-hand side so that line goes out and
now when you add them up 117 and 13
times 9 is also 117. triple figure
quadruple any figures you like
i tried to trace this back and i found
it's very difficult because people in
rural areas before schools in victorian
times and long before that used to use
this in elizabethan times we know they
used it this system of doubling and
halving but i traced it back even
further i traced it back to about four
and a half thousand years ago
in egypt and they did it a slightly
different way
so let's say you want to multiply 9
times 13 again all right what they would
do is write the 13 down and here they'd
write a 1 double it 2 double it 4 double
it 8 double it sixteen stop we don't
need sixteen we're only multiplying by
nine so we got enoughs two thirteens
twenty six two of those fifty two two of
those hundred and four okay they were
told there's only one way to make nine
from these numbers on the left hand side
and sure enough it's eight and one makes
nine so out goes that one
and now goes that one
and thirteen and four is seventeen
hundred and you've got the same answer 9
times 13 equals 117
that was the egyptian method
now
can we link this very old mathematics to
the present day
yes we can let's do this one let's score
the ones we used were the one
and the ones we didn't use with the
naught
reading up and what you would get is one
no not one and one not nor one
is the binary number four nine why is it
the binary number because it's made up
of an eight and a one binary numbers
work like this one two four eight one is
there two is one of those and none of
those three is one to eight four is one
of those and none of those five is one
of those and one of those a four and a
one and so on and here eight and one is
nine and that's the binary number for
nine the binary number for 10
would be one
0
1 0 okay
and that would give you 8 and 2 is 10
and sure enough 10 times 13 is 26
104
is 130.
so all this ancient mass
is linked to the very mass that makes
our computers work our televisions work
our satellites and everything else
digital information
it's what makes the world go round today
this episode was supported by brilliant
i'm a big fan of their daily challenges
like these you should really go check
these ones out
but to get your teeth into more binary
have a look at brilliant's beautifully
prepared courses
now brilliant's not all about what you
get right or what you get wrong although
i do prefer getting them right if i'm
honest they're much more about getting
smarter in a way that's enjoyable and
engaging there's lots on the site you
can look at for free or go along to
brilliant.org
numberfile for 10 percent off their
premium subscription that unlocks all
the good stuff
brilliant.org numberphile there's even a
link down in the video description if
you don't want to type it in
[Music]
it's quite amazing you take you want the
binary number for any number give me a
number to find the binary number 20
29 right 29 they're ready the binary
number half of that is
14 and a half forget the half however 14
is seven half of seven is three and a
half forget the half half of three is
one and a half forget the half right
and the binary number for 29 is one
one
one
not that one
because it's even
one
one one one not one so if you want to
find the binary number of any number you
write it down
reduce it by half for getting the
fractions not score the numbers one or
zero going up and that will be the
binary number for any number you choose
it's so simple